NPR's popular show Morning Edition  announced that after 40 years they are  introducing a new theme song it's this  kind of big news in the NPR world here's  just a snippet take a listen that's the  song not judges I think it sounds  professional yeah you know what's weird  there's more to the song as the song  goes on it really starts to change  direction I'm gonna play just a bit more  check it out News News NPR news Morning  Edition news you snooze you lose because  we tell you the truth you get what you  choose so choose on news where NPR news  it's  [Music]  you get up when you're a little bears  look at the world and scratches where we  got the news that you need the ears or  Center damn mouth and let me inators  we'll search of what you need to know  this we know you're busy and you're on  the go now move did you I shot a bill  turn your hair from spray  [Music]  you